[Music]
we of course been following the storm on
the east coast very closely we have a
lot of friends and family there and some
of the photos that have been tweeted and
shared online are just incredible
uh but this has been reported a lot i
want to mention this
people and it's true people have been
making fake storm photos and posting
them online first of all like who would
do that who takes the time for that so
just as a warning i'm telling you there
are some fake uh storm photos out there
for example this is a real photo uh
taken by a real journalist and here's
another completely real photo right here
but we're pretty sure this next one's
fake we're we think
we're not
our eye on it actually no it might be
real
i've had that cab driver uh
last night during the height of the
storm in new york city michael
mayor michael bloomberg went on tv to
ask the public to only call 9-1-1 for
serious situations yeah which you think
would be obvious all right well
apparently the city is getting uh 9-1-1
their 9-1-1 system they're getting 10
000 calls
almost every half hour most of them are
for complete non-emerging people don't
know how to use 9-1-1 yeah and and
they're getting all these calls for
stuff that are not emergencies and i was
curious like what are these people
calling in we were able to get a hold of
some and we're going to play them for
you now this is the height of the storm
take a listen
9-1-1 what's your emergency my leg is
broken the building's on fire and
someone's shooting at me
is there a command on halo where i can
pause
hi i'd like to report an emergency the
jets
you saved my life
[Applause]